I'd started a business before that I raised four million bucks of other people's money,...
...started a web marketing company,...
..went boom and bust with the first dot-com boom and bust.
I knew I wanted to make it as an entrepreneur and start another business,...
...but I had no idea what I wanted to do.
And so for inspiration, I went surfing...
...and I planned a five-month surf trip around Australia and Indonesia.
The inspiration came before I even left.
I wanted to capture photos of myself and my friends...
...that I was going on the trip with while we were surfing out in the water,...
...and no camera existed that allowed you to do that.
And so I set out to develop this wrist harness...
...that I could put a single-use disposable camera into and surf with it.
And I didn't even mean it to be a business idea.
I just wanted to document my experience on this trip.
And as soon as I got it working well, the light bulb went off and I realized,...
"Oh my god, there must be so many other surfers in the world...
...that want something like this."